i
[Música]
a
el centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu le ha pedido a los
estados que se preparen para recibir la
vacuna facer a partir del 15 de
noviembre lo único que haría falta para
empezar esta distribución sería la
aprobación de la administración de
drogas y alimentos de eeuu el general
custer na que lidera la operación works
será el encargado de la distribución los
trabajadores de la salud los
trabajadores esenciales y aquellos más
afectados por el cofidis serán los
primeros en recibir las vacunas su
distribución no será fácil primero
porque las vacunas tienen que estar
almacenadas en una temperatura por
debajo de los 75 grados celsius y
segundo porque hay que aplicarse dos
dosis dejando tres semanas entre las
vacunas para contrarrestar estos retos
pzifer se comprometió en enviar las
vacunas a los estados en cajas con
hielos secos para asegurar las
temperaturas
[Música]
luego de que facer y manteca anunciaron
que su vacuna contra el coi 19 demostró
en forma preliminar ser eficaz en un 90%
el presidente argentina alberto
fernández dijo que el país podría contar
en diciembre de este año con dosis de
esa vacuna para 750.000 personas pero no
es el único acuerdo que argentina espera
tener con productores de vacunas
fernández también anunció que prevé que
en diciembre estén disponibles dosis
para 10 millones de personas de la
vacuna rusia es pública por otra parte
el presidente aseguró que en marzo de
2021 el país podría contar con dosis de
la vacuna de astrazéneca y oxford que se
fabricará en argentina para casi toda
américa latina además estas
negociaciones para recibir algunas de
las vacunas que están desarrollando en
china por ahora no hay ningún envío
confirmado en forma definitiva ni ningún
fabricante de vacunas ha publicado en
revistas científicas con revisión
resultados de sus ensayos de fase 3 de
todos modos argentina se prepara para
tener lista la infraestructura de
almacenamiento de distribución y
aplicación de las vacunas que finalmente
pueda conseguir
[Música]
la vacuna será gratis esa fue la
afirmación del ministro de salud
colombiano fernando ruiz al ser
preguntado por la nueva vacuna de facer
y biotech el máximo responsable de salud
también dijo que las primeras dosis
llegarán en el primer trimestre de 2021
de entrada el gobierno espera vacunar a
unos 15 millones de personas entre las
que se incluyen adultos mayores
pacientes con comorbilidades y
trabajadores de la salud colombia
obtendrá 10 millones de dosis gracias a
kóvacs una asociación de 140 países que
hicieron un fondo común bajo la tutela
de la o ms para poder competir
económicamente con los países más
avanzados y que trata de ofrecer un
acceso equitativo a vacunas seguras y
eficaces los otros 5 millones vendrán
por acuerdos bilaterales tras esta
primera tanda de vacunas después espera
hacer lo propio con las personas en edad
productiva hasta alcanzar el 60 por
ciento de inmunidad en la población
cuando se conseguiría la ansiada
inmunidad de rebaño y la pandemia pueda
quedar atrás
[Música]